[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
hey folks welcome back to the Dark Horse
podcast live stream q a 134 we are ready
to go yes we are here we go so every
week we invite our friends at the
Discord server uh to vote on their
favorite question because we didn't do a
q a last time uh we invited them to
supply us two this week
and Fairfax is not all that excited by
this but uh but we are he's big on
answers he doesn't like the questions
yeah
um
all right unfortunately you guys are
missing the yawns he's doing the yawns
below the screen we definitely need a
cat cam in here yeah okay so let's let's
jump right into the two Discord
questions before getting to the audience
questions the other audience questions
this week
more and more people are turning to Big
fertility for reproduction via egg
donation IVF and gestational surrogacy
what are some of the biological
repercussions of these practices
this is potentially a giant question yep
yeah
um yeah they're they're all different
really there's there's not a single
answer
you know egg donation IVF gestational
surrogacy are going to have distinct
both uh biological and uh
call it sort of moral and cultural
implications yeah I mean I think the the
problem is you have a giant
chestertons
fence raised to the the eighth power
issue here which is how many different
things are happening in the process that
you have
separated that are then lost and what
are their implications and you know the
idea of you know can you describe the
things that will go wrong no you know
it's a little bit like well we're going
to make a massive uh disruption to your
immune system you know can you predict
the exact failure it's like well
no but yeah no it's and it's like GMS
right
um presumably some genetically modified
organisms
we'll be fine
and uh can you guarantee that there will
be no unexpected effects no you cannot
and anyone who says that you can is
either not good at their job or is lying
so let's just begin to
piece this out right so uh gestational
surrogacy was one of the things right
and that one actually yes gestational
surrogacy is one of them and that's
that's the one
um I guess egg donation a little bit but
gestational surrogacy
um to me feels like it's got the most
moral quandary associated with it
because uh you know just just like I
don't applaud the uh the sort of third
wave feminist uh Applause around sex
work as if you know this is this is just
a choice that that women make
um listen
um
I think uh that gestational surrogacy
very much risks and we know in some
cases absolutely does
uh effectively abuse usually women of
lower classes who have no other options
and who you know uh people don't dream
of being prostitutes when they're little
girls nor do they dream of carrying
someone else's child right right that's
that's that's no one's idea of
um the life that they desire for
themselves and um that doesn't mean that
people will not end up having made those
choices but the but uh it pretending
that uh this is uh that those choices
are made utterly freely uh is a pretense
well I think it you know it you're
hinting at this but it goes even one
step further which is you know just as
it turns out to be true that very often
for women having sex produces feelings
of love and that that means that in a
culture that has decided it is
sophisticated to have sex with people
you don't intend to invest in long term
that that puts women at particular risk
this also you know what does the fact of
being pregnant when you are a creature
such as we for you know the only way in
which an ancestor would have gotten
pregnant is to actually get pregnant and
therefore that means that the child
you're carrying is yours and that means
that it would be very natural for you to
have feelings of protectiveness and uh
and all towards that developing child
and so to turn this into an economic
relationship yeah and when in which you
in which from the very origin it was you
know it's it's different from
someone who doesn't want to abort but
also is not in a position to have a
child and so intends to give up their
child for adoption as soon as they're
born which itself is an excruciating
decision as I understand it for people
and very very hard for for many women
who give up their child
um but the you know the origin of the
child was not economic from from the
beginning presumably in those cases and
so you know what
personally I cannot I cannot fathom
going through nine months of gestation
with uh a business decision
um integrating with everything about my
body my anatomy and physiology uh and uh
that has to have some effects on the
developing uh embryo and then fetus and
then child yeah and we are headed into
Brave New World territory here because
first of all just dating a child and
birthing a child is destructive it's
very costly it's not a physiologically
free thing and so I noticed right so the
question is right there's a there's a
reason that we do not allow you to
auction your kidney on eBay right you've
got two kidneys you could decide I'll
take the risk that uh you know I will
need a set of my backup kidney and I
will auction my my backup kidney to
someone else and I'll I'll just face it
we don't let you do that because we've
decided it's not moral why because
exploitatively people you know some you
can't auction on eBay but some people
have donated oh you can donate a kidney
but I don't think you can't sell it all
right
um I see the distinction so the point is
we do draw a moral boundary and the fact
is giving up a kidney is a very
constrained finite fact a kidney is
different than a generalized Damage Done
to the body on behalf of somebody who's
willing to pay you to carry their child
so it's both more constrained in space
and time and less right it's well that's
it you you will not regrow a kidney once
once given up you're Forever Without
that kidney but
in most lives the effect will not
um will will not will not you won't end
up you will not die of kidney failure
whereas
um you know
say and I don't I can't imagine that
this is a description for most
surrogates but a gestational surrogate
who wasn't otherwise going to have
children
um yes
um carrying a child to term uh has very
real
um health effects on the body many of
which are negative but some of which are
positive right like actually you know
there are reductions in some kinds of
sex-specific cancers associated with
um both breastfeeding in particular but
also from gestation yeah instance uh
absolutely I don't think the issue is
well understood with respect to to
breastfeeding but I do think it reduces
uh tumors for reasons that have to do
with shortening telomeres that are
longer than they would be in an ancestor
but with regard to gestational I think
um like ovarian cancers uh right are I
think if memory serves ovarian cancer is
lower
um for women
um
for women who've had children of born
children of their own versus not and
then lower yet
um I think the more kids you've had on
the earlier you had them
so there is a very deep moral question
here right
you can't
sell your kidney yeah as far as I know
you can sell you can rent out your womb
okay I don't think these things are
fundamentally different in any way I
think you are accepting a kind of damage
and risk of physiological damage and
risk which then provides an advantage to
wealthy people who wish not to suffer
that damage at the expense of others so
exploitation is a very real concern on
the other hand
what are we to make of you know if Red
Bull
wants to incentivize people to do stupid
things while wearing a Red Bull helmet
and drinking Red Bull at the Finish Line
right we allow that now I think it's
grotesque
but I'm not sure it should be forbidden
so there's a question about
are those two things different right are
we going to allow you to jeopardize
yourself for the aggrandizement of Red
Bull and not allow you to rent out your
womb and not allow you to sell your
kidney it's not clear why you would draw
a distinction between any of those
things they all seem to be of a piece
yeah and either we're gonna not allow
you to be exploited that way
collectively or we are going to allow
you to be exploited yeah but I mean
there is also there's um you know the
the way that the conversation sounds
uh the you know the third wave and later
feminists and some other sort of
overlapping groups
um would have us celebrate choices like
sex work yeah and so-called sex
positivity and I imagine things like
gestational surrogacy and uh it strikes
me as
um you know being realistic and
understanding that uh if the technology
exists this will sometimes happen
um but it's actually not
um
an exciting Fortune for someone to have
landed on is is a way that maybe some of
the costs can be mitigated
yeah I don't I think it exists in a
weird middle ground because it's kind of
unnecessary and I think it well there
will be I mean so you know a gay male
couple
well let's put it this way I mean it's
unnecessary if your point is uh there
are plenty of kids available for
adoption there are plenty of foster kids
out there there's plenty there's plenty
of children who could use loving loving
parents and if the thing that is driving
you is you really want your genes or in
the case of a gay couple one of your
even only just one of your genes
um in your kids well that's kind of
retro and weird and why do you why do
you get to do that at the cost of some
woman who needs to rent out her womb in
order to pay her rent right and I think
the world still fetishizes genes which
is Downstream of some very despicable
stuff and you know what I think uh I
would say from The evolutionary
perspective is that genes ain't all that
with respect to humans that because we
are so software based yes your genes
want you to pass them on that's kind of
the point of the exercise but you don't
have to listen to them and they don't
know anything right real point is
the other stuff you pass on but then
let's just say there are a lot of
complexity is implied right gestational
surrogacy takes one woman and puts her
artificially and temporarily in the
position of somebody reproducing which
may have changes in state that matter
triggered in her when in fact her
commitment ends at Birth right
and then on the other side what you're
doing is you're taking a woman who
hasn't been through those things which
are a natural part of triggering the
patterns that result in motherhood
unfolding properly and well and
short-circuiting them another can be
physiological reasons a person may be
incapable
of carrying their own child but the
point is I mean a lot of a lot of women
throughout history have ended up being
mothers without having been pregnant so
I feel like that that side of it
adoption is all well and good yeah right
but my point is the child is suffering a
transition from one parent who gestates
to another parent who raises them
and maybe for no reason right if this is
an adoption well there are plenty of
kids who need adopting
um it means that whatever the
value of breastfeeding and I think you
and I I know that you and I both believe
that there are many values that occur in
that process and that the idea that this
is just simply like a food dispensing uh
phenomenon is just wrong right right
it's an information dispensing
phenomenon it's a bonding phenomenon
it's all kinds of things and so implicit
in immune kick
right implicit in gestational surrogacy
is the breaking of whatever those values
are and so
may be necessary in some circumstances
hard to know what those circumstances
are given that there are kids who need
adopting yes it's easy for me to say as
somebody who you know has
not adopted and has two kids
but
let's just say the fetishizing of genes
is at the root of a lot of this this is
how you get your genes somewhere without
going through this process and while
there are medical things that can force
this at one level they don't necessarily
Force this rather than just simply
adopting
yeah
um but then you know egg donation IVF
um you know I think I think there will
be and maybe we should move on to
another question here but there will
certainly be effects
for all of these things but
um
you know we we do know a number of
people who've used IVF and uh
successfully I think in fact I think we
don't know any people who have tried it
and it has not been successful and have
abandoned it
um maybe I'm wrong on that front but uh
and we also know some of those children
and they're amazing and those families
are amazing and
um
uh you know are there are are there
chesterton's fence issues
of course it's possible of course well
what I would do is I would say there are
comparisons right we can't say this is
fine that isn't fine probably all of it
has some cost some of those costs may be
very small like removing the appendix
despite the fact that the appendix has
value the cost of it a modern person is
very very tiny right
um
so we can compare gestational surrogacy
for example to egg donation now my
instinct would be one of these is way
more fraught with chesterton's fence
risks than the other yep right egg
donation seems safer now I don't know
what the effect is on the woman donating
the egg but from the point of view of
the person just stating yeah this feed
is from the get-go is the woman who's
gestating is going to be the the mother
of the child and she has functional
anatomy and physiology sufficient to
carry the child and to therefore then
also lactate for the child and her uh
her partner uh will be both the genetic
and the you know de facto father of the
child and the only thing not of the two
of them is that the eggs had to come
from somewhere else
that is
um pretty uninvasive yeah it's a pretty
a lot of ways and yeah yeah I I think my
instinct is the number of places where
that can be uh seriously harmful it's
pretty small yep and maybe maybe close
to zero yep
yep
cool and IVF is sort of at that end of
the
um my concern with IVF would be the
technical disruption right that just you
know if it's accomplished well the
better the technique probably
uh the you know minimal harm but yeah
unless there's there's one question
about you know
why the sperm and egg burnt meeting on
their own
um but assuming that that's not a a
um meaningful incompatibility yeah and
there's really a question about well how
destructive is your lab technique and
hopefully it's not very destructive and
if it isn't then it seems like a similar
question to uh
to the surrogacy versus egg donation yep
okay the second question from Discord
this week we have already addressed but
I will read it again here California has
declared that Bumblebees are fish as an
evolutionary biologist do you concur
with this classification and then they
appear to quote from the uh the legal
document
um fish ellipses as a term of art is not
limited solely to Aquatic species
accordingly a terrestrial invertebrate
like each of the four bumblebee species
are fish
so we've talked we've talked about this
before like
um
no
bees aren't fish but also legal
documents aren't scientific documents so
what makes sense as the law tries to
make sense of pre-existing legal
documents which presumably were laid
down before we knew as much as we know
now about systematics
you can't simultaneously be held
accountable to a document written before
we understood what we know now and
responsible to
um to what we know now and trying to try
to mesh those legally it's not going to
be possible so yes this sounds absurd
but it's a it's a legal thing it's not a
scientific claim
yeah I mean
this is simple there are lots of places
where we file something in a weird place
for convenience and we're not confused
and right this sounds like that yeah
totally all right uh first question from
the Q a this week is
in your discussion with Matthias Desmet
am I pronouncing his name correctly I
believe so okay in your discussion with
Matthias Desmet you discussed the
possible evolutionary payoffs taking the
example discussed if prisoners in the
gulag were the two main evolutionary
survival strategies be brutality
or SEC brutality psychopathy atomized
survival of the fittest versus holding
on to humanity
if so could we then apply this to the
forces behind the global Mass formation
to learn something useful about the
evolutionary or psychological forces
that are driving this
thanks
well I'm having a hard time recovering
who what benefit I I can't
figure out what I can't quite parse it
because I haven't listened to your
conversation yet yeah
um
you want to try that one more time try
to read it again okay in your discussion
with Matthias Desmond you discussed the
possible evolutionary payoffs payoffs
um first thing is payoffs to whom I know
yeah period uh taking the example
discussed if prisoners in the gulag with
the two main evolutionary survival
strategies be brutality psych brutality
slash psychopathy parentheses atomized
survival of the fittest versus holding
on to humanity
okay I will do my best here I think we
are talking about what the incentives
are to a person who has become subject
to totalitarians what do you do in the
gulag right
do you retain your integrity do you as
as the person who has been become
subject to the totalitarians what do you
do right okay and
I think the souls and it's in
perspective which is not an evolutionary
perspective but it gives voice to an
evolutionary
force that we can find elsewhere the
real point is one about lineage right
what is it that you are trying to
preserve are you trying to maximize your
chance of getting out of the gulag
intact right maybe there's an argument
for that there's certainly an argument
for that if others depend on you and you
are trying to get out so you can do well
by them
and then there's a question about
whether your lineage is well-being
depends on your integrity right so I you
know I hate to use this example it's
obviously not a gulag but the analogy
isn't that far off
and Frank did a tremendous amount of
good for her lineage though she did not
survive right she gave us a window into
a child's understanding of the The
Tyranny descending on her family
and
I think there's no question in her case
you know I'm not suggesting a child
should ever make such a decision or have
to make such a decision but in her case
the way it played out her contribution
to the world was probably substantially
larger having died and left the record
she left then it would likely have been
if he had gone on to be a above average
level of success having survived the
Holocaust in other words we have a small
number of things that tell us what
actually happened and what it was like
for the people involved and what it
might be like for you if you're facing
such a thing and that is a obviously a
very important artifact and so it did a
tremendous amount of good for whom well
for the world but certainly for the
lineage in question as well so there's a
there's a similar discuss you're saying
lineage you how you you're talking at
all scales presumably for her family but
specifically for European Jews yep and
for people you know Ashkenazi Jews Jews
in general are persecuted regularly
history that's a phenomenon and we can
talk you know people
ah the the
um reflexive critics have of course
reacted so badly to my once again
pointing out that what the Nazis did was
monstrous but from the point of view of
spreading their genes it was not insane
right and people do not like this point
they really dislike it and I frankly I'm
I'm angry at them because the key to
preventing this from happening again is
understanding the logic behind it well
so I mean the flip side of that not not
you know let me steal man their argument
I'm not going to try to do that here um
but we also see among many people a
desire when
the leaping to oh if you disagree with
me you must have a mental disorder you
must be schizophrenic you must be
sociopathic you like there's no possible
way you could disagree with me you must
have a mental disorder so that's that's
like the other version of this which is
also terrible like no actually sometimes
people just come to different
conclusions that doesn't mean that they
have a mental disorder similarly
actually those horrible evil people at
in the charge of the Nazis who who uh
had a lot of people in Mass formation
working on their behalf uh were not
inherently
um mentally disordered like this it's
the same point actually and and the the
narrow-minded
um Frank narrow and small-minded both uh
people who would claim that actually if
you disagree with me or if you do evil
you must have a mental disorder
are it's the same it's the same mistake
that people are making in both cases
well actually so I have
the problem is the term evil okay the
problem is people think that you can
assert that something is evil because
it's terrible right that it's a measure
of Badness I don't believe that that's a
proper definition of evil right because
evil suggests a desire to do harm
rather than an indifference to harm
and the problem is if you are Advanced
you know we do all kinds I'm not sure I
agree with that definition
well then what does Define that
distinction we need the distinction
between trying to do harm versus
indifference indifferent to doing harm
right there's lots I don't I'm I'm not
sure but I think both qualify as as um
as potentially as as actually no I think
both qualify okay but that's the problem
then because but it's not that's that's
not saying anything about mental
disorder that's that's the distinction
I'm making it is because
the desire to do harm for its own sake
is not a rational thing
and so my point is I don't know that we
call it mental disorder because I don't
know mental disorder has a connotation
of an organic dysfunction a malfunction
of the brain
a relishing of the doing of harm
where it is not productive for oneself
in other words if I'm willing to suffer
in order to hurt people then there is
something disordered and my point is
that we cannot say that about somebody
who is indifferent to harm that they do
in the production of profit
I'm not saying that we should tolerate
the indifference to harm in the
production of profit but I'm saying
these are two very different questions
because I I don't I don't disagree that
they're different well but your the
problem is we don't need to worry very
much about real evil because it's not a
good strategy so it does not get
elaborated by Evolution the thing we
have to worry about is ruthlessness
indifference to harm that thing is like
wildfire if you do not
inflict the cost upon it right and so
the a there I we need a term for people
who relish the doing of harm they exist
right they're an anomaly they are not
productive they do not spread because
they are involved in a bad strategy okay
we do have to worry night and day about
people who are willing to do harm to get
ahead right those people are a dime a
dozen so
that distinction has to have a term
driven to do harm versus
um that will accept it as a collateral
damage right exactly so my claim is evil
is sort of the high bar that's the worst
term we've got and my point is that one
ought to go to people who like doing
harm for its own sake and then short of
that maybe so I guess I'm not I'm not
gonna I hear what you're saying I'm not
going to acquiesce to this
categorization because I I want to draw
it out and look at it and be like I feel
like there's we're missing categories
here we're missing axes on which to draw
these distinctions maybe it may be more
useful maybe but my point is nobody
looks at a successful Mafia Dawn and
thinks mental disorder right yes we
understand this this one I can get I can
get behind you right right but but
that's my point is we all get what that
is organized crime right is about the
fact that hey if you organize this crime
it gets away with it if you did it one
off every individual participating in
their individual part of the crime might
end up imprisoned or dead right but if
you organize yourself sufficiently well
so that you have criminal accountants
and criminal lawyers and if you have a
criminal apparatus well then it's a
business okay that's a successful
strategy yes we have to stamp it out but
the point is we understand it as
rational and then we know something
about what to do about it
why we make the mistake of looking at
the Nazis
and thinking that it's not organized
crime right this was a this was an
organized crime and
was it top level despicable
absofreakinlutely but was it
ununderstandable was it crazy no and
this is just this is my point again and
again is this is rational and any time
that you don't always know that
something is rational you may have to
wonder about it in the case of synopsis
we don't because we know they left
really good records of what they were up
to yeah right we can see what they were
doing and we could understand why if you
think from a lineage perspective this
makes a ton of sense which is why we
have to build safeguards so it can never
happen again right and anyway to refuse
to understand it is to invite it to
happen again and you know look I'm
entitled to be angry at anybody who
wants to run that risk I'm entitled to
be angry about it as a human being but I
get to be doubly angry about it as a
Jewish human being right because who's
it going to happen to again right it's
going to happen to Jews it always
happens to Jews so
um so my feeling is look let's just
once and for all be clear-headed about
this and when I say lineage in Anne
Frank's case I am talking yes you're
right the point is lineage is a fractal
parameter she did a marvelous thing for
Humanity it may not have been she may
not have understood herself to be doing
that probably didn't but she did
something marvelous for Humanity she
also did something marvelous for
lineages of persecuted people right so
that they could see something for one
thing once you've understood that this
girl was trapped in this terrifying
situation
and she didn't make it right her family
didn't make it and that now we have it
didn't her father make it I believe yeah
yeah it got saved yeah but the point is
nonetheless knowing that that was the
Fate knowing that stories don't end
happily yeah right that this particular
story was terrible and then it ended
awfully yeah right that is motivation to
not let it happen again that is
motivation to be willing to die on the
hill so that you you know might survive
and
um
I I think that's really important so in
the gulag
similar logic May well apply and
uh you know
anyway you can you can extrapolate from
it which you will but yes there is a
lineage argument for retaining your
integrity at some risk to you're not
surviving the gulag especially if you
leave
something behind that might warn others
I do
next question
I have lost trust with a medical
establishment even my doctor because of
covid-19 policies vaccines Hospital
protocols and denial of early treatment
I think I'm not alone
what to do how do we find doctors whom
we can trust in this world of censorship
having a telemed covid-19 doctor doesn't
solve the big problem are we truly on
our own
uh yeah I mean I think uh you I think
I'm not alone he says in the middle of
this question no you're not alone at all
there are a lot of us who were already
um
picky as it were about uh about doctors
and insisted on asking questions and of
of them about why they came to the
conclusions they did and some doctors
would never abide that and we steered
clear of such doctors but covid-19 has
revealed a whole nother level of
of both incompetence and Corruption uh
in terms of medical practice that said
uh we we know doctors uh here in
Portland and elsewhere who are excellent
and one of the things that and and other
health professionals one of the things
that has become a rule of thumb for me
and had become before covid as I was
seeking various kinds of Health Care to
help me after the boat accident that I
experienced in Galapagos in 2016
was that the MDS were quick to
um
quick to want to prescribe drugs and get
their knives out and and suggest surgery
it seemed like a fairly blunt and
limited toolkit and the dos the
osteopaths uh the NDS the naturopaths
and various other types of body workers
such as some chiropractors and strain
counter-strain therapists and massage
therapists and physical therapists you
know all of whom there are presumably
extraordinary practitioners and terrible
practitioners and that is true for MDS
as well but among those slightly more
slightly to much more alternative kinds
of Medical Practice you are I think more
likely to find people who are well well
positioned because they've chosen to go
into these fields
um
people who are well positioned to hear
questions from their patients that they
might not have thought of before and are
therefore interested in investigating
further
yeah I agree and it's interesting I
would say how many
I did not know much about osteopathy
until
uh until we got to Portland and
started seeing an osteopath I find it
fascinating that this field exists and
the discovery of what it is and why it
potentially is implicated in so many
different pathologies that we treat
badly with more conventional medicine or
more standard medicine is very
interesting
but another interesting allopathic
allopathic medicine is is the word that
is that is used
um out there to refer to basically
standard Western medicine all right
so
what has been secondarily interesting so
our experience our initial experience of
osteopathy is pre-covered by a lot the
number of heterodox coveted doctors who
are osteopaths rather than MDS is
interesting in its own right so there is
something about being in the
heterodox medicine field that probably
opens you to heteronoxy and we have seen
a good deal of that and it's fascinating
yeah indeed
all right
I was in a Whole Foods in Cambridge
Massachusetts recently and saw a guy
wearing a face mask and a t-shirt that
said science not a liberal conspiracy
I cracked up laughing next to the
overpriced avocados had to tell you guys
yeah um
yeah the problem with that one is that
one is now being wielded uh in as a
banner of follow the science
witches
uh science not a liberal conspiracy
I don't think I'm following
um the idea being that those who are
concerned about coveted heterodoxy to
see our mistaking science for a liberal
conspiracy and it's not one and that's
not what's going on in fact the science
and science are two different things
right but I mean that's the point here
is this is someone who thinks that
they're all in favor of science but
they're wearing a face mask presumably
one that's not doing them any good right
that's the observation I just think it's
unclear what the meaning is it's unclear
what the person is regarding as science
okay so everyone has a different
interpretation of some memes but
um
I think that's often going to be the
case
um
how did rattlesnakes evolve to have a
rattle
love you guys
well I don't I know we know a couple
things that are relevant yeah but not
the answer to that maybe there may be
people who do know
but one thing is that tail wiggling
makes a rattling sound in leaves and
there are snakes that do that now it's
possible that they are doing that
secondarily to rattlesnakes once
rattlesnakes exist and you become
sensitive to the idea of a rattle then a
snake who can simulate it by wiggling
their tail and some leaves especially if
you're not looking right at them
um may be mistaken for a rattlesnake
yeah but the um there are snakes who
wiggle their tails
um who are both not some Patrick
rattlesnakes and not within the cartel
it's not um not closely related to and
therefore sort of Downstream
phylogenetically of and also not in the
same Geographic range as rattlesnakes
um the two of which things together
suggest that this is a separate
um a separate discovery of shaking the
tail as uh you as a as an effective
defense even if it doesn't make the
noise that the rattle does right but the
problem is if it evolves secondarily but
after
selection has invented rattles then it
could be playing off the experience of
creatures that not if they're not some
Patrick no even so even so I mean for
one thing you know birds fly and their
experience of rattlesnakes
it's possible
um anyway I've got a hypothesis about
king snakes and coral snakes that plays
on the same Trope but leave that aside
so rattlesnakes are limited to the new
world
and you've got
um old world snakes who wiggle their
tails you do yeah okay
well
um so if you have old world snakes who
wiggle their tails and that suggests
that a snake warning mechanism exists in
the tail wiggle then the evolution of
something that allowed a snake who was
not in a place to create so if you were
a snake that dwelled in dry leaves you
can wiggle your tail and make a noise if
you were a snake that wished to send the
same signal but you might be on dirt and
therefore there's nothing to Rattle then
having a rattle on board would create
that phenomenon and then I would guess
because the rattles a
chamber of the rattle is added each time
the snake sheds so it could be that a
snake that is incompletely shed has a
little dry rattly thing
at the end of its tail briefly oh that's
interesting yeah
okay and actually yep just so happens
we've got we've got some rattlesnake
skin right here I actually
don't remember if this is Rattlesnake or
not uh I don't know I I collected some
rattlesnake skin a while back is this I
don't know if this is what I collected
or if you collected this separately
um you should be able to tell
[Music]
you there it is
um so here
can you hear that
so that
could
if it either was hanging off the end of
a snake it wouldn't completely shed or
was sitting in the burrow
constitutes the basis for a rattle so
the question is how
yeah these are keeled these are killed I
think this is rattlesnake I suspect it
is I think I got it in Dry Falls
um you think this is one you found one I
found I think so well yeah you just got
it off your bookshelf that doesn't count
well no but I think that's how it made
it onto my bookshelf
um but anyway
so somehow this material I'm killed oh
means there's a little vertical so and
the anterior anterior posterior acts as
the snake
um the scale is running this way so the
overlapping down the vertical line of
each scale there's a medial Ridge and
when you get close and you get close to
a Viper which maybe you shouldn't do if
you don't really know what you're doing
actually you really shouldn't do if you
don't really know what you're doing so
that's the value that's the venters
um
you'll see a little Ridge and that's a
oh goodness
um
that's a I think a pit viper
characteristic maybe a larger than that
it's just a Viper characteristic and the
the collubrid's the uh rear Fang snakes
don't have killed scales
so the question is in the shedding
something evolves an adaptation evolves
to create a permanent uh little bubble
that presumably has something inside of
it that rattles around and it is a
modification
maybe if what did you call the event
scales just ventral scales Central
scales yeah I'm sure there's a name but
I'm not a good enough herpetologist to
remember what that is
um
so anyway something gets retained there
and one can imagine some series of
things a warning sound uh from the
twitching of a tail uh evolves into that
sound being made from the rustling of
snakeskin uh to a retention of snake
skin I don't know if this is is the
rattle I mean this is all easily
discoverable with a book or a Google
Search and we have the book in fact we
have the books right here hey snakes
um right there oh you can't see that
um
I don't know if the rattle is
keratinized or if it's
like I don't actually know what it's
made of
uh or is it you know is it just is it
like hardened it's hard dermis is it
epic like what I don't know what it is I
don't know either but this book this
excellent book for those of you who like
this conversation this book called
Snakes by Harry Green who um I think
he's still active at Berkeley
herpetologist at Berkeley
um we'll have all the answers you want
or at least some of them yeah
or at least some of them
okay
um
next question
recently a 101 year old SS guard was
sentenced to five years in prison for
his crimes during the Holocaust
where is the point that Society
negatively crosses from Justice to
Revenge
that's interesting well you know I don't
think it's so simple
um I don't think the question suggested
simple well but no it does suggest a
threshold between two things and it
seems to suggest that revenge is not
a legitimate instinct ah and okay what I
would say is first of all you've got to
figure out what the system is for
if the system is for
preventing genocide
then it may be that as little purposes
there is in incarcerating a an ancient
uh participant
that the message that one sends to those
contemplating participating is you you
will never live this down you will never
outlive your guilt you this is
permanently what you become if you
engage in this and we will punish you
even if we find you at the very end of
your life right so while there's a part
of me that feels that this person if
this person is not a a born monster if
they're not at least sociopathic right
if this is a person who can feel guilt
and was caught up in some Mass formation
and then the world returned to its
normal flawed State and this person has
had all of these years to think about it
and presumably you know look themselves
in the mirror thousands of times and
remember what they've done and feel
shame then there'd be very little
individual point in doing it but the
larger purpose of all of these things
right we
we punish people
for various reasons and even our
Instinct towards vengeance is about
driving up the cost of engaging in
Behavior so they don't reoccur and
there's no place more important to do
that than when it comes to genocide and
so uh
I understand the question but I don't I
don't think it's a simple one I think
the real question is is this liable to
be effective will somebody who might
engage in such a thing hear of it and
think better
um and if so then I think this person's
right not to be incarcerated because
there's no value to it is a minor price
to pay in light of what they apparently
chose to do earlier in their life huh
okay
I'm gonna try I I'm not sure how this is
supposed to be punctuated
love you guys working at SpaceX
with you and Eric since Brett first went
on Joe with Jordan Peterson
um I don't know why that's the only last
name I decided to include let me go back
include all the last names
Joe DiMaggio I guess we know more
Jordans than we know Joe actually been a
lot of Eric's too hey let me start over
yeah yeah I'm not I'm gonna do the same
job trying to interpret the punctuation
but I'm Gonna Fill In the last names
here
love you guys working at SpaceX with you
and Eric Weinstein since Brett Weinstein
first one on Joe Rogan with Jordan
Peterson what about going back to the
Moon
I've never been to the Moon
I think we should go back to the Moon I
think that uh
that
that focusing only on uh on
I think the idea
of us getting a colony to the Moon is
short-sighted and silly
and misunderstands what humans are and
what the environment is and what it
means to live a high quality life
but the idea of space exploration as
something that has been uh
argued to be a waste of time and
resource and we really need to fix the
problems on Earth before we start
thinking about things outside of Earth
is uh
similarly short-sighted and
um and narrow-minded because
um just just as looking out into the
ocean and looking at into the night sky
when you can actually see it when it's
not so polluted by light pollution is
mind expanding and gives you a sense of
what the possibilities are what what you
might discover that you can't even
imagine yet
if we as a species are focusing only on
narrow problems that we can already see
right in front of us
in in some cases anyway that is going to
cause people to despair more quickly
than they would if they were allowed to
imagine Futures uh that they haven't yet
begun to see
yeah I agree and I think we have a
I'm not even sure I know the name of
this puzzle
it's the inverse of a chesterton's fence
problem
it is very hard to specify what the
value I think even of a moon Colony
would be but the exercise of producing
one while it has nothing to do with
making humans substantially more durable
I think it might involve enough of the
right kind of problem solving I mean
remember remember the biosphere
experiments here on Earth
didn't work I heard bias sphere the
biosphere well that's pretty much
everywhere now but biosphere the
biosphere experiments and I don't think
we're gonna self-enclose we're gonna
build a thing big enough into which
nothing can come and out of which
nothing shall go for a year or something
like this right and we're gonna we're
gonna make it totally self-sustaining
and they didn't work didn't work because
it's actually a harder problem than you
think right teaches you an awful lot
that was on earth right and that was on
Earth and so if we took the kind of
dedication that it would take to return
to the moon and to establish a permanent
presence there and
got serious about it then we would learn
an awful lot about closed systems that
are very unforgiving and you the problem
is we have too few people who really
understand how difficult these puzzles
are
and so we are managing what we've got
with Incredible recklessness in part
because people just don't Intuit the the
fragility of what functions yeah so I
would like to see us do it because
frankly I believe we waste such a
spectacular amount on absolute garbage I
mean the amount that humans spend on
uh porn and frivolous games and
I don't know I don't even really know
how Tick Tock works though I checked it
out once but whatever the point is the
the hugeness of the investment in all of
these not only unproductive but
counterproductive
modes of time wasting and basically
energy generation and heat generation
that that
some tiny fraction of it could be
redirected into something that is
productive in just learning how we work
and what we need and that that would
produce a lot of jobs for engineers and
that it would be worth doing in and of
itself even though it's very hard ahead
of time to put your finger on what the
positive externalities that come out of
such a program might be well that's and
that's the thing like that's the
distinction that um you know in Academia
we refer to as you know the distinction
between basic science basic research and
applied research right engineering is
inherently applied like an engineering
project is one in which you were trying
to solve a problem you were trying to
create a thing
and science although applied science
exists uh
at its most fundamental science is oh I
observed a thing I observed a pattern I
want to try to figure out what explains
it or what it means or what else given
if that is true what else must be true
and in order to do that first I have to
figure out the thing that I think I saw
I did is actually real or it was just an
artifact of my own sensory biases or I
was there at a particular moment in time
or whatever that's all that's all
science and is extraordinary and you
should never have to justify what are we
going to you know how will this better
Humanity or else I won't let you we
won't fund you we won't let you ask
those questions
but I would argue that art in a
different way plays a similar role for
people and it's not always different
people but often different kinds of
people who are drawn to Scientific
Endeavors that don't have an obvious
applied angle and Artistic Endeavors
that aren't making functional art but
making art that is not clearly it's not
going to hold water it's not going to
you know do a thing specifically you
know it's not design maybe but it will
cause people to stop and think and
that's stopping and thinking or that oh
my God from this angle it looks like
this and from the saying it looks like
that and that causes me to have an idea
that I can apply over here right you
know Art and Science both do these
things that are
are blocked in their success if you
mandate in advance that you know what
the outcome will be
I think
you
I think you nailed it when you said
basic science right those of us who get
this understand the basic science of
science where you don't know what you're
looking for you're just trying to figure
out how things work and this is
terrifically productive and the problem
is there's this huge
um bias in modern times for like what's
it for justify the work based on how it
will help us and this is of course
largely industry driven and etc etc but
okay basic science is the thing that we
have lost sight of
so what we're really looking for here is
a distinction between basic exploration
we don't know what we're looking for
we're looking to put a colony on the
moon because it would be great to be the
kind of people who have the knowledge of
how that would be done it's a very
difficult job it's doable
um we will be we'll be an upgraded
species at the point we can answer how
you do it right so basic exploration
versus prospecting
right if you're going after asteroids
not because you really give a damn about
what asteroids are made out of because
you like heavy metals yeah but because
you want to take Precious stuff and haul
it back to Earth we all get why you're
doing it but the point is you're not on
board with the basic exploration program
and the basic exploration program is
what made humans great the app that's
that's exactly right and those the
conflicts you'll have on a team of
explorers between the so-called basic
science explorers as you know as coined
right here uh and the Prospectors are
going to be the most enduring and
stereotypical and easy to predict and
hard to resolve yeah and of the conflict
on your team yes and the people who are
like actually I am just really
interested and I want to figure out
what's here as opposed to nope not here
the thing I came looking for is not here
therefore we have to go over there
because we haven't checked there yet
yeah
now I would argue that you really want
the teams to be limited to the basic
folks well it depends on what it depends
on what the teams are for well and you
know maybe you may be asking the
question of like what's it for is
specifically over in applied prospecting
space anyway it gives too much power to
the prospecting space and it also I
think opens a Chasm of perverse
incentives part of the problem with the
prospecting folks is that because
they're in it for the profit rather than
doing something that generates a profit
as an externality then they have a
reason to keep the research going even
if it's not productive rather than right
if you're if you're into basic
exploration yeah then you don't really
want to explore
if if a if you're in a cul-de-sac and
there's nothing more to find there's
nothing valuable in continuing to to
fund that research you want to fund
something that actually might lead you
somewhere new whereas you can make a
career in a cul-de-sac if you're a
prospector if in lieu you know you keep
promising the government that you're in
pursuit of something that's going to be
really valuable to people and really
what you're doing is you're in a jobs
program that you've created yourself and
you pretend that what you're doing is
valuable and maybe what you're doing is
gain a function research on viruses and
you're putting Humanity in danger but
you've spooked the hell out of some
bureaucrats who now think that your
research is the thing that's going to
prevent a pandemic and in fact the whole
ironic thing flips on its head you
create the pandemic and we end up here
yeah intentionally smooth some
bureaucrats yeah well you intentionally
spooked some bureaucrats to get them to
find your research and recklessly did
the research that created the problem
that you claimed was so dangerous to
begin with
truth is Stranger Than Fiction
that is true
and more contagious
uh we about an hour Zach
okay well we haven't gotten through very
many oh we've got a lot of questions
here
um I'm gonna let's get through a few
more here
what no fly swatter
see earlier point about the messes they
leave the men are so gross oh who looks
at a fly swatter and thinks that's done
problem solved no there are certain but
people who use fly Setters do not end up
with toilet water covered flies flying
around their bathrooms after midnight
yeah but they also don't innovate a
whole new way of dealing with flies that
work so freaking well I mean you know do
you know how many flies I had to go
after to get that one video
this the one from this morning yeah no
one oh it works that well right so yeah
I'm telling you man the flyswatter
people I don't trust them really oh
that's where we are that's where we've
landed I don't no look okay can I ask
you a question yes
um
you ever looked at windshield wipers no
never once yes all right
does that look done to you does that
look like a good answer to the question
or does that look like the first answer
to the question I know it's raining
squeegee's a good idea
are you just you just responded to the
fact that until like yesterday we had a
car that we'd owned for years and the
rear windshield wiper made a horrible
noise no what every time the windshield
wipers go on I think I can't believe you
thought you were done with the design
that is a prototype on every single car
on the road it's a terrible answer to
the question yes it's better than
nothing but
squeegee's on an arm that sweeps back
and forth over your windshield that is
not finished okay I do not like to be
this guy but where's the better idea
well that's the point is people aren't
looking for it because they think
windshield wipers is enough just the
same way they think fly swatters is
enough so I thought you were going to
complain about the coverage and you know
some cars have better coverage than
other with that radial sweep but then
there's all this stuff up here that
never gets covered but if you seriously
arguing against squeegee as a response
to water sheeting on glass
what else are you gonna have well
if I was going to thank you if I was
going to producer agrees oh oh the
person does not agree with me right and
you know be quiet producer
um look what do I look the problem with
this kind of work is
you have to prototype something yeah it
will by definition suck but it will tell
you what you need to know to ask the
next question and so what sucks about
the squeegee on glass
so many things okay okay first of all
you get a little how do we get here um
because if somebody said fly swatter and
I can't believe anybody on Earth thinks
that's a good answer to the question of
what to do about the Flies do you think
a fly sweater is equivalently bad as
windshield wipers yeah I think they're
about equal answers to the question two
different questions obviously hello yes
it's that way okay the squeegee
well one okay it blocks your view of the
road
okay okay two
it's difficult to get the right level
right there are rainstorms that are so
intense that the squeegee can't really
keep up with the water there are
situations in which you have to dial it
way way back because a tiny amount of
rain is accumulated it's very hard to
get it too you're joking now right no I
think that this is such it's a cluge and
we've all become accustomed to it we've
all become accustomed to it because it's
better than nothing I mean if you're
gonna drive in depending on how fast
you're driving 20 to 100 mile per hour
don't you know drive 100 miles per hour
when it's raining but if you're gonna
drive in 20 to 60 mile per hour winds
which is effectively what you're doing
during a rainstorm yeah
you're gonna have to get the water off
the windshield well it depends what I
believe there's probably I'm not saying
100 but I believe there is probably a
solution to be had with driving air that
prevents the water from hitting the
window right
now I don't know that it makes sense
energetically speaking but I would like
to know if there's a mechanism that
could keep the window dry so that this
didn't happen I mean look it's crazier
things have happened a sea otter a sea
otter his skin doesn't get wet right now
you're solving a different problem but
the point is well wait a second here
listen to me you got a small animal yes
I do in cold water a lot of surface area
per unit of volume any energy he wastes
touching cold water is causing him to
have to forage more so he has this
incredibly dense fur which almost caused
them to go extinct because it's so dense
that we nearly hunted them to Extinction
but the point is why is it so dense
because it's actually capable of
excluding the water from the skin itself
so the animal isn't wet right now the
windshield is a different issue but well
but the point is not not allowing the
winner to get wet
is a better solution than allowing it to
get wet and trying to shunt the water
away with a waving arm with a squeegee I
I don't think so all right I I think
equally good as the solution is we shall
prohibit driving in the rain
yeah I mean it could be a coating uh
then you've got the coating spewing off
of the environment and that's not what
we're up taking into the wait can people
hear you Zach
okay so unfortunately you shouldn't be
contributing much because people can't
hear what you're saying but you should
be miked at some point hopefully during
our lifetime somebody will replace the
windshield wiper with something that
actually doesn't suck I will not eat my
hat I will eat this snake skin perfect
yeah and you can have sauce if you want
but I like I'll eat snakeskin you eat
snake skin sure all right sounds kind of
oh it's not my Preferred Choice of you
let's put it this way you can have a
chaser Chaser better than grubs
probably yeah I've had grubs
yeah they weren't good Ecuador yeah yeah
it's just the one actually I don't want
to yeah once you've tasted I'm done that
species of grab you've tasted yeah
actually it was just the one yeah
I don't remember which species so my bad
but yeah snakeskin dead skin I mean not
appealing but no appealing is exactly
how you end up with a pile of dead skin
like that yeah yeah but I mean this is
maybe this is just me but this is a lot
prettier than you know the skin that
comes off of a mammal yes flaking off
totally rest okay
we have ended up some strange places
today we have it's the isopropyl that
we've been breathing you've been
breathing I've got a contact high or
something
um oh boy there's so many good questions
here uh let's just do three more and uh
apologies for not getting to a whole lot
of questions guys
three more
is childhood pickiness an adaptation for
the child's health or a leadership test
for the parent
I'm not signing up for it being a
hundred percent the latter but yeah
yeah look there's a difficult problem
the difficult problem is in a world of
things that you could put in your mouth
most of which you probably shouldn't for
various different reasons how do you
figure out what's good what's not good
what to prefer your ancestors had
different concerns like uh let's let's
think about it from a a cat's
perspective rather than the human for a
second there's a question about what can
a cat eat and then there's a question
about
what
amount of investment does it take to
find a particular animal
right so there may be animals right
there right and maybe animals out there
that are perfectly fabulous to consume
but the reward the return on investment
for pursuing them is too low and so an
aversion to them that caused a cat to
default to something more profitable
would be positive so there may be
considerations like that in human
pickiness that don't have anything to do
with what's good for you and not good
for you I guess I would think in that
case you wouldn't expect an aversion
a rep you would rather expect a
um don't pursue to the degree that this
is totally delicious you know downrank
your Pursuit
you know well I just don't want to take
off the table the possibility right
suppose there's something I suppose
there's something that is
rewarding initially but that you so
quickly deplete the local supply of them
that you could very easily get suckered
into pursuing them and then like they
they get something that's they offer
something that's so delicious that
you've become addicted and that's it
that's or even even you know
the reproductive structure of the
population is such that although they
are relatively easy to catch they are
very expensive if you pursue them
because you'll catch the first two and
solve almost none of your problem and
then you'll be pursuing others but
you'll have to move far afield to get
them or something like that if it's a
proof of concept but that's why I would
say rather than an aversion
um having having such things on a
opportunistic like if you see it go for
it right don't don't you know don't
avoid it if you see it but don't go out
if you're ready to pursue it yeah is is
a is a just a I agree that's the first
thing I would expect yeah but my point
is I would expect a range of tools to
dissuade you from this and that you know
there should be things like let's say
mushroom aversion mm-hmm
mushroom aversion mushrooms are
profitable to eat they can be sourced
the problem is
if you Source a bad one
erases the gains that you might have
gotten from a lifetime of eating good
ones and so the point is
everybody feels a little sketchy about
mushrooms at first and maybe the point
is the sketchiness about mushrooms is
really about the hazard of
distinguishing and it really shouldn't
be about hey I have somebody properly
Source these or better grew them so you
know exactly what you're looking at
there's no risk whatsoever in it right
that the idea of well would you eat a
mushroom well tell me more about this
mushroom how much do you know about what
happened do I lose a liver if I eat that
mushroom right you don't know and so the
point is the aversion might be not about
the fact that a healthy mushroom is
not a good thing to want it's that
you're you know you know nothing about
mushrooms and that it's roulette it's
mushroom roulette
um anyway so what would the aversion
that people typically have to mushrooms
at first
is that correlated to the roulette
nature of mushrooms
right and my guess is it is yep so
anyway
introducing to that Spectrum kids and
hey here's a
refrigerator full uh Supermarket full of
various things you could eat
um and you get chaos because yeah well I
mean so one of one of the predictions of
um sort of our our thinking generally
will be that
to the degree that childhood pickiness
uh exists it is
vastly an artifact of the weird world of
the hyper novel World in which you've
got not only a lot of new stuff but
you're mixing stuff from a lot of
different cultures such that if you know
if you if you happen to live in a city
with fabulous food like we do here in
Portland and you know we didn't live in
a city with fabulous food and our kids
are really young but if we if we had and
if we had had the resources to be going
out to a lot of the different
restaurants it might have been you know
Thai food than Ethiopian food then
Mexican food then you know then Chinese
food then you know like just you know
all the different places which you know
until
a hundred years ago you know 500 years
ago for some people but for almost no
one was it a possibility that you would
get exposed to that many different kinds
of culinary Traditions with that many
different ingredients with that many
different preparations
um in as a child or really as an adult
at all and so you know what would it
mean to be picky if you're uh Kung uh
eating mostly you know mongongo nuts and
other dog tubers and occasional and and
leaves and meat hunted and and brought
back like oh oh I I don't do wildebeest
like really okay you're an idiot right
like no childhood bigginess doesn't
exist in that environment right and you
know it may be the very rare unfortunate
child that actually somehow has like an
allergy to mangongo nuts which I'm just
going to keep saying because I like to
say it uh and that child probably
doesn't
um do very well right because there just
aren't that many uh staple ingredients
in most uh uh historical cultures yeah
so I would add one more thing in light
of your your kung example which is I
would expect
zero pickiness around truly edible
things that were actually present in
your environment If you experience
hunger as a child
which if you experienced hunger yes all
ancestors would have and so I would say
one thing that is almost certainly true
of modern pickiness is that it's
Downstream of huge abundance yeah and
the one reason that the one caveat here
is I could imagine somebody
who had an impoverished childhood
8 outside of the normal range of edible
things we had students for example whose
families you know cook roadkill right
it's not something most of us would want
um but we always had their choice right
but we all get how you would get there
and you'll be like hey better than
nothing right but such a person might
grow up into somebody who didn't want to
eat mushrooms that were well sourced
because it had not been available in
their childhood environment so they I
would expect the pickiness not to arise
relative to foods that satisfied real
hunger in Youth and then to be sort of
arbitrary at the point that you reach
adulthood and face new foods right no
and actually I mean to get back to you
know I mentioned
um eating larva before you know there
are cultures where
um where this is part of part of what
you do and okay that's if that was part
of what you were eating growing up
uh presumably
that's that's part of what you enjoy
eating now as an adult but the idea of
being told as adults in cultures uh
where there hasn't been part of our our
background like you know you're going to
do this now and you're going to enjoy it
I think that's actually not how any of
this works right I mean it's like these
dick tots around you know this is the
way you're going to use language now
it's like that's not how language works
this doesn't have dietary Choice works
then you know this is not done
um by an authority saying now you like
this nope now I don't and probably now I
never will because that's how you
approach me with it yep absolutely yeah
two more all right thoughts on the musk
Twitter deal falling through are we just
[ __ ] out of luck on spaces for public
dialogue love you guys thanks for all
you do
um
very disappointed about the Twitter
thing uh maybe that a court forces Elon
to acquire Twitter I must tell you that
this is now perplexing to me that
Twitter which did not want to be
acquired now does want to be acquired
because now we realize it's not as
valuable as we thought it was the whole
thing is a little complex but it's all
complex but anyway there are other
avenues
I am not going to say more than that but
there are other avenues and to the
extent that elon's argument was
extremely compelling about why we need a
public-spirited Twitter that honors Free
Speech we still need it
Elon knows it other people know it so uh
stay tuned all right watch the space
last question for today
what oh
sorry we just got another big big one in
so we're gonna do two more questions all
right I just hit refresh and we got
another another giant one two more
questions
what if the evolutionary advantage of
group formation is a tribal War footing
this suspends normal activity and
inoculates the group from dissenters and
enemy propaganda
being a temporary phenomenon allows them
to quickly resume normal survival
activities once the war is won
totalitarianism hijacks this innate
response by perpetuating the perception
of danger
would it be possible to reduce this
response by exaggerating The left's
Narrative turning both sides against the
narrative
um this is hold on I I am struck by this
I think I need you to read it again yeah
I came up with an idea on the road trip
that Toby and I were on
that is in very similar territory okay
so I just want to see if it's the same
idea this sounds this sounds intriguing
um
it just came in like three minutes ago
what if the evolutionary advantage of
group formation is a tribal War footing
this suspends normal activity and
inoculates the group from dissenters and
enemy propaganda
being a temporary phenomenon allows them
to quickly resume normal survival
activities once the war is won
totalitarianism hijacks this innate
response by perpetuating the perception
of danger would it be possible to reduce
this response by exaggerating The left's
Narrative turning both sides against the
narrative
okay I don't know about exaggerating the
last narrative but let's put the rest of
the model
so it's not the same idea that I came up
with is quite a good idea
um
let me just rephrase it see if I've got
it right
the idea being presented here is that
when one is going to war when your
lineage is going to war
it ought to become deaf to
things that could be propaganda right
your enemies May Seed bad ideas into
your mind so you will fight badly
against them and that this footing this
Mass formation
is
a temporary inoculation against things
that sound reasonable because they might
well be approaching horse ideas well and
and dissenters right he says here so you
know enemy from within as well if even
if those people don't view themselves as
the enemies yeah I think there's a lot
to that a lot of it's true I think I'm
trying to figure out what I've heard
pieces of this thought pieces of it but
the question is how you know how much is
that model already reflected in a rent
and Desmond and various other people
that we've talked about or two on the
podcast yep
I will just say the idea that I came up
with which is I think related but not
the same had to do with
uh the dehumanizing
dehumanizing is a term I recognize is
ironic here the the humanizing that is
inherent to
the process of hunting
and it has to do I won't I I want to
cover this idea later but there's
something about the story of piggy in uh
in um
oh
uh Lord of the Flies yes no I've
forgotten yes right Lord of the Flies
that story involves dehumanizing piggy
yeah and they hunt him take a Piggy's
little boy who gets murdered right and
they hunt him
animal-like which is not unlike they
give him a nickname that makes him sound
like he's not human that he's a hunt
worthy creature yes and they talk
themselves into being indifferent enough
to his well-being that he is killed by
these other children
um anyway it's obviously a fictional
story but nonetheless there's something
chilling and realistic about it and
reminiscent of witch hunting generally
so anyway my idea was over there this
idea is
yeah closer to
the mass formation and the departure
from reason that we see in these masses
and yes the use of fear to trigger this
so
the problem that I see in what's
presented
is it describes the pathological version
of this it describes a model that is not
inherently pathological right that is to
say if we are to go to war then we need
to be immune to the propaganda of the
enemy and to dissenters who might
disrupt us
um but then something takes control of
that mechanism and uses it against the
lineage's interest which is not always
the reason for Mass formation
right so this is actually the exact
thing that Matthias does when and I
disagreed over is my point is not
inherently pathological right
um so anyway interesting interesting set
of questions there for sure yeah
all right final question
why do saunas and Hot Yoga feel so good
is the heat good for you
I've never done hot yoga but I've heard
it feels really good and uh
I was never a fan of the idea of a hot
tub or a sauna and uh man I am I'm a
huge fan of sauna at this point and
um
yeah the heat is good for you the heat
helps clear some of
um some of what ails you
it helps it helps your body actually get
rid of some of inflammation and just
detritus
so I have a mechanistic sense and I have
no idea whether it's accurate or not but
if you think about think about the
experience of jumping into a tolerably
cold body of water right so you're
jumping into a river the kind that
you'll jump into it's cold but then two
minutes later you say oh it's fine it's
actually fine so we're not Alpine lake
level yeah but it's it's fine once
you've been in it for 30 seconds water
right we've all done that
why is that true
well it's true because your ancestors
were starving right not every minute but
they didn't have enough food and any
food that they burnt now in order to
stay warm was food that they had to
replace with more food later and so the
point is you are very sensitive for
reasons that have nothing to do with
your health
you are very sensitive to cold because
cold is waste and waste is starvation
later all right so when you jump into
that really cold water your body is
saying no no this is terrible it's bad
you're losing lots of energy to the
environment that's not a good thing
right now at the same time what it is
doing is it's trying to minimize how
much water how much energy you're going
to lose to the environment and how does
it do that
it shuts down the circulation of the
periphery so I was discussing a few
minutes ago that an otter doesn't touch
the water the water is excluded from the
immediate contact with the skin
true there are places where it touches
but but the fur is so dense that it
keeps the water away from the skin right
it's like a dry suit as I understand it
so your body has a version of that
that's not nearly as good as the sea
otter
um and I did I was talking about sea
otters not river otters but
the your body shunts blood away from the
periphery it takes it away from the skin
where you're contacting the water so
that you have an insulative layer of
skin that's not perfused with uh with
blood
buffering your blood that's actively
circulating from the cold water so you
are losing less heat you have a fixed
surface area you jump into the water you
are losing less heat per minute at the
point that your body has adjusted your
circulation right so 30 seconds in
you're not it's not as wasteful as it
was when you first jumped in okay so
um
yes true right so
remind me of what question I'm answering
uh why do saunas or hot yoga feel so
good why is the heat good for you okay
so take the model I've just deployed
about what happens when you jump into a
very cool water right and imagine that
there's a version of the story that we
could do with heat right where when you
are exposed to heat what do you do you
try to radiate how do you radiate well
by opening up your capillary beds right
to by profusing your your periphery with
blood so now imagine that you as a human
hacker of One's Own physiology you say
well actually when I jump into something
cold I'm going to close down my
capillary squeeze all that blood out
there that has some capacity to mix some
capacity to take whatever maybe pooling
in these other structures and probably
drive it into the main circulation where
your kidneys and your liver can get
access to it and going between like
sauna and cold plunge which is is common
in many cultures right will will
basically get your circulatory system
activated purging moving everything
through clearing out detritus right and
in some sense I would say there are a
lot of processes that actually work like
this right if you're if you were
building a machine that involved gears
that meshed and things that slid right
if you put a bushing on a rod
right you would slide it to its full
extent several times to make sure the
lubricant was distributed in the right
places make sure it slid freely if there
was a burr you'd find it so the point is
pushing something to its extremes
actually has a kind of a built-in
recalibration value it has a and totally
comparable to this you know why does
sporadic extreme effort do a better job
of keeping you in shape than regular
intermediate levels of effort yeah you
know exercise like well I just you know
I do 30 minutes of the exercise bike
every day at the same level like well
okay you're probably not at really high
you know you're probably not obese if
you're really like moving yourself that
but
um if you challenge yourself to the you
know to the Limit
you know assuming that you you know your
heart can handle it and all of these
things you know if you're not a doctor
not giving medical advice here but
um you are more likely to send your body
the signal of actually sometimes you're
gonna have to do this yeah sometimes
you're going to be expected to do this
so you better get ready for this as
opposed to yep every day we do the same
thing so I'm going to accommodate I'm
gonna you know make sure that we have
enough calories on board to deal with
that and you know the you know doing the
same thing every single day is going to
leave you in um you're less prepared for
anything outside of that Norm so another
another way to say that is if you reach
the limit of Your Capacity let's say
that you do something that forces you to
that limit like a race right you're not
going to win this race if you're the
best runner in the race maybe you don't
get to Your Capacity you probably do
because you probably run flat out but
you might not right but if you're not
the best uh person in the race does it
depend you know if you're talking about
like an ultra marathoner versus a 100
meter Sprinter it's different different
what what does capacity mean right but
whatever it is if you're if you're an
elite athlete then the point is well I
want to cut as many seconds off this
Marathon as I can so I'm going to push
myself to the Limit right that as soon
as you've reached a limit or gotten very
close to it then the point is the body
can infer
well how do I know you're not going to
need five percent more capacity than you
needed this time and so the point is we
better build that capacity right so and
this is like I'm like I'm terrible at
this but
we can apparently almost all of us if
not all of us hold our breath for much
longer than we think we can yeah right
your your body four times yeah your body
tells you you're out of air you're going
to die yes very very much earlier and
you know same thing with like you know
plank or
um you know it's harder if you're
actually if it's an actually like an
active exercise but like oh I can't do
it like yeah you actually can
you actually can get over the mental
response because your brain is telling
you stop and then when you don't stop
your body goes like Oh actually I guess
I have to do this right well the the uh
holding your breath one is interesting
because the logic of it is pretty clear
when you think about it right at the
point that you've expended a quarter of
your total capacity and the point is
well
how hard exactly is it going to be for
you to get back to the surface are you
in a cave are you gonna have to find
your way out and so the point is yeah
let's alert you early yeah the the
Sprite needs to set in early because if
there's any way you do not want to get
to you know three quarters of Your
Capacity burned up and then start
searching yeah right so that's right
that's right
um okay I said that was the last
question but there's one comment here uh
that I want to just say and we aren't we
aren't independently assessing the math
but in response to something you said in
the first oh no the first hour yep here
it is from 1.8 meters uh which I guess
is sort of like the average height of a
human being yeah uh with 180 degree
Vision yeah you'd see about 40 square
kilometers which works out to about 200
humans per meter squared
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait so
the thing he didn't say there oh if you
took everybody if you took everybody if
you took everybody 200
humans per meter Square that's not gonna
work no you'd have to stop and work oh
and he almost don't stack well well
suppose we built buildings in it oh
never mind
200 humans for me to scratch I'm way off
yeah yeah I want to check the math but
uh thanks and uh ouch but okay yep all
right
um I think we're there yeah I think we
uh you know we we covered a lot of
things today we did yeah yeah
um we'll be back next week for live
stream number 135 and with a q a
following in which we'll address your
questions uh come join us on patreon
come join me at substack Natural
Selections address your questions and
question your addresses and all the
stuff that we do here on Dark Horse we
will not question your dresses though
because we can't see them right if we
could we might but we can't
indeed yes all of those are obstacles
independently sufficient to prevent it
yeah
um it was just the one really no we
can't see them
yeah that's that's fundamental yeah sure
yeah all right
until next week be good to the ones you
love eat good food and get outside be
well everyone
[Music]
foreign